الناتو تركونا وحدنا
والجميع خائفين..
لقد صارح شعبه بمرارة الواقع.
سأل ٢٧ قائدا أوروبيا عن انضمام أوكرانيا
للناتو لكن أحدا لم يجبه على سؤاله،
الجميع يلتزم الصمت تجاه أزمة أوكرانيا،،
فما هي فاعلة كييف لترد على
هجمات موسكو العسكرية؟
موسكو تسيطر على مفاعل تشيرنوبيل النووي،،
يا ترى ما هو التالي؟
وواشنطن تعلن إرسال٧آلاف جندي إلى ألمانيا..
وروسيا ترد أنها تسعي لتحييد القدرات
العسكرية لكييف ولن تستهدف المدنيين،.....
والشيشان تحشد قواتها استعدادا
للتوجه إلى أوكرانيا..
وعقوبات أوروبية على بوتين
ولافروف وبوتين يقول أنها
لن تجدي معه ويكرر التحدي...
كل ذلك ليس إلا غيض من فيض
الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية
وإليكم البقية.....
الداخلية الأوكرانية تعلن استئناف الجيش
الروسي لهجماته على كييف لليوم الثاني
على التوالي وواشنطن تعلن إرسال
٧آلاف جندي إلى ألمانيا...
وأنباء عن سقوط أول صاروخ
على حي مدني في كييف
(بينما كانت روسيا قد أعلنت عن استهداف
القدرات العسكرية والمواقع الحيوية لحكومة أوكرانيا فقط
لكن التقارير تقول عن سقوط ضحايا من المدنيين
داخل أحيائهم...)
بينما يجري توزيع للأسلحة في أوكرانيا على المدنيين
لمحاولة التصدي للقوات الروسية
التي يمكن أن تقتحم  المدن..
وترخيص من البرلمان لجميع أطياف الشعب
بحمل السلاح والدفاع عن البلاد خلال هذه الحرب..
فهل تعيش روسيا حرب العصابات والشوارع
كما حصل معها من قبل في أفغانستان؟
(سفير أوكرانيا لدى اليابان)
فقدنا السيطرة الكلية على مفاعل تشيرنوبيل النووي...
وسيطرت عليه القوات الروسية
لكنها لا تعرف كيفية التحكم به،
بينما احتجزت القوات الروسية جميع العاملين
في المفاعل...
الدبابات الروسية تتقدم نحو العاصمة كييف....
وسماع دوي انفجارات قوية جدا في كييف
والسلطات تطالب المواطنين بالاختباء
في الملاجئ فورا،
في اليوم الثاني للعمليات العسكرية لموسكو
في أوكرانيا
خرج الرئيس الأوكراني
فولود يمير زيلي نسكي وقال:
هذا الصباح نحن وحدنا في الدفاع عن بلدنا تماما
مثل البارحة،
وأقوى القوى في العالم تراقب من بعيد...
عقوبات الناتو ليست كافية والجميع في أوروبا
خائف من الوضع...
ومجددا تساءل زيلي نسكي عن الضمانات المقدمة لبلاده،
والحقيقة المؤلمة أن أوكرانيا
ليست بعد عضوا في حلف الناتو...
فلا أحد يرد على أسئلة زيلي نسكي بهذا الموضوع
فقد سأل٢٧ قائدا أوروبيا
إذا كانت أوكرانيا ستشارك في الناتو ولم يجبه أحد...
لكنه يقول لسنا خائفين من روسيا
ولن نخاف من الدفاع عن بلدنا
..
وأكد زيلنسكي أن القوات الروسية حاولت التقدم
في جميع المحاور لليوم الثاني على التوالي للغزو
لكن قوات كييف منعتهم من ذلك...
لكن ما قد يحرك مشاعر الدول حول العالم
هم المدنيون وهنا قال زيلي نسكي في كلمته ،
أن الضربات الروسية استهدفت أهدافا عسكرية
ومدنية على حد سواء، وفقا لما نقلته رويترز.
واعتبر أن "العقوبات المفروضة على روسيا غير كافية"،
مضيفا أن "العالم يواصل مشاهدة ما يحدث
في أوكرانيا من بعيد".
وأردف زيلي نسكي: "تلقينا معلومات عن دخول
مجموعات تخريبية تابعة للعدو إلى كييف"
، داعيا السكان إلى اليقظة والتزام حظر التجول....
متعهدا بالبقاء في كييف، بقوله
"العدو حددني على أنني الهدف الأول،
وعائلتي هي الهدف الثاني".
لكننا لن نتحرك قيد أنملة عن كييف
وسنظل ندافع عنها أنا وعائلتي في المقدمة
...
زيلي نسكي جدد طلبه من أوروبا بعزل روسيا
وتشديد العقوبات عليها..
وكما طالب حلف الناتو بتقديم مساعدات
دفاعية لصد هجوم روسيا..
لكن هل تعلمون منه زيل نسكي؟
بعد رؤية اندلاع الحرب في أوكرانيا..
ها هو العالم يتذكر الرجل الأول في أوكرانيا،
فولود يمير زيلي نسكي الذي كان يوم ما
ممثلا ونجما تلفزيونيا
ودخل حديثا إلى السياسة،
ثم أصبح رئيسا عام ٢٠١٩..
(لكن سياسته قادت البلاد إلى الحرب
فكيف سيدير الحرب وكيف سيخرج منها؟)
زيل نسكي الذي أدى دور رجل عادي
وصل إلى سدة الحكم في أحد المسلسلات
عام ٢٠١٥
وهذا مقطع لزيلي نسكي
وهو يتحدث عن الفساد، انتشر هذا المقطع
وأكسبه شهرة واسعة وشعبية متزايدة،
وهو ما ساعده في الوصول للحكم...
والشيء البارز أن مغامرته السياسية
بدأت بما يشبه المزحة في أحد المقابلات
بإعلان ترشحه للانتخابات..
وها هو اليوم يكرر دعواته لشعبه بالهدوء
رغم كل المخاوف  التي تحيط به،
زيلي نسكي فاز في الانتخابات لكن مواجهته
هذه المرة مع الدب الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
قيصر روسيا!!
هذه المواجهة ستكون بشكل مؤكد
نقطة تحول في رئاسة زيلي نسكي
لكن هل تكون نقطة مضيئة أم ستكون النقطة
الأسوأ في حياته وحياة أوكرانيا بأكملها؟..
(الردود تتوالى)
الشيشان يحشد قرابة ١٠آلاف جندي
ويعلن التعبئة العامة لدعم العمليات العسكرية
في أوكرانيا،،،
الرئيس الشيشاني قديروف وبحسب وكالة أنباء
"سبوتنيك" قال:
"إذا كنت تريد حقًا الالتقاء بنا،
فنحن ندعوك بكل سرور إلى فوج أحمد حاجي
قديروف"، مشيرا إلى أن المقاتلين الشيشانيين
الذين يتم إرسالهم إلى أوكرانيا يتموضعون
في أكثر المواقع سخونة.)
مسؤول أوروبي ....العقوبات بدأت
بقرار أوروبي بالإجماع على تجميد أرصدة بوتين
ولافروف... لكن بوتين يرد بأنه لا يأبه لعقوباتهم
وسيرد عليها في أقرب وقت...
بينما الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون يقول
بوتين خدعنا جميعا.. فنحن كنا نتفاوض
بشأن اتفاق مينسك.. قبل أن يشرع بوتين
بالاعتراف بجمهوريتين غير شرعيتين،
ثم يبدأ عملياته العسكرية.. إنه خيار واع ومدروس...
بينما كان بإمكاننا تجنب الحرب والوصول للسلام..
وزير الدفاع البريطاني
(روسيا فشلت حتى الآن في تحقيق أهدافها في أوكرانيا..
وفقدت ٤٥٠ من جنودها خلال اليوم الأول للغزو...
وهي تريد احتلال كامل التراب الأوكراني...)
الجاليات العربية في أوكرانيا تتواصل مع بعضها
مكونة أسرة صغيرة، للتوعية والتكاتف والابتعاد
عن الإشاعات.. ويدعون أفرادهم إلى ترك أماكنهم
إن كانت مشتعلة بالقصف،
أو البقاء إن لم يكن هناك استهداف لغير المناطق ا
لعسكرية،،، لأن ذلك أمر خطير جدا...
الحرب النووية تعني حربا عالمية ثالثة بدون شك...
فعلها بوتين وقرر بدأ العمليات العسكرية
لغزو أوكرانيا
(ففي البحر الأسود تتمركز ٦ من أكبر السفن
البحرية الروسية ومئات الفرقاطات
والزوارق الحربية، وإذا تطورت العملية
فذلك يعني قطع وإغلاق طرق التجارة الدولية
وتضرر الدول المطلة على البحر
كتركيا وجورجيا ورومانيا وبلغاريا)
(أما إن تم غزو العاصمة كييف،
فلا أحد يعلم بشكل المواجهة ولا حجم الخسائر
البشرية أو المادية لهذه العملية،
وأليكم مقارنة بسيطة بين القدرات العسكرية
لكل من روسيا وأوكرانيا
(القوات البرية)
عدد جنود روسيا ٨٥٠ألف
بينما لدى أوكرانيا ٢٠٠ألف جندي
لدى  روسيا ١٤٤٢٠ دبابة
أما أوكرانيا  فلديها ٢٥٩٦
تمتلك روسيا ٣٠١٢٢ مدرعة
ولدى أوكرانيا ١٢٣٠٣ مدرعة
(القوات الجوية)
عدد الطائرات الروسية ٤١٧٣
وعدد الطائرات الأوكرانية ٣١٨
عدد الطائرات المقاتلة الروسية  ٧٧٢
لكن عدد الطائرات المقاتلة الأوكرانية ٦٩فقط
عدد المروحيات الهجومية الروسية ٥٤٤
وعدد المروحيات الهجومية الأوكرانية ٣٤
(القوات البحرية)
أسطول بحري روسي ب٦٠٥ قطعة
وأسطول بحري أوكراني ب٣٨
١١فرقاطة روسية
مقابل فرقاطة أوكرانية واحدة
١٥مدمرة روسية
ولا تمتلك أوكرانيا أي مدمرة
ميزانية الدفاع الروسية (١٥٤ مليار دولار )
ميزانية الدفاع الأوكرانية(١١.٨٧ مليار دولار )
وبهذه الإحصائيات كلها كيف سيتعامل الغرب
مع روسيا التي تمتلك أيضا ٦٥٠٠ رأس نووي،
وآلاف الصواريخ الباليستية؟
وفي المقابل أوكرانيا التي تمتلك أكبر جيش في أوروبا
ومن خلفها حلف الناتو الذي يضم ٣دول نووية،
(فيما لو اشتركت هذه الدول فستحدث
الحرب العالمية الثالثة حقا هذه المرة)
مقاطع فيديو تنشرها قوات جمهورية دونيتسك
الانفصالية تظهر أسر جنود أوكرانيين..
قائلين أن أكثر من ٣٠ جنديا أوكرانيا
ألقوا أسلحتهم وتم اعتقالهم بعد ترك قادتهم
لهم في أرض المعركة...
الدفاعات الأوكرانية تسقط مقاتلة روسية
والطائرة تسقط وتصطدم بعمارة سكنية
مكونة من ٩ طوابق وتشعل النيران فيها
وأدت إلى مقتل طفل وإصابة ٦ آخرين..
بينما وزارة الدفاع الروسية تنفي استهداف المدنيين
وتقول أنها تستهدف المواقع العسكرية والنقاط الأمنية
ولن تستهدف المدنيين فالمدنيين ليسوا
في خطر كما ذكرت الوزارة الروسية...
وسيظل الموضوع بين شد وجذب وكل طرف يتهم الآخر
وهكذا هي الحروب لكن هل تصل هذه الحرب
إلى نقطة لا يمكن العودة منها؟
هل تسبب حربا يخافها جميع من في العالم
وستكون هي الثالثة من نوعها؟
نأمل ألا يحصل ذلك...
لمتابعة ما يجري في غزو أوكرانيا
يمكنكم متابعتنا في قناة شاهد لتعرف
لنطلعكم على كل جديد..